do not disappoint you're into Johnny
Michael's podcast
political strategist and political
commentator first time on the show
hopefully not our last
can't wait to talk to her about a tweet
she had the other day Sherry how are you
I'm doing well thanks for having me on
it's good to be here absolutely so you
you said you sent a tweet out I think
you were replying to someone the other
day and you were talking about this plan
and I I've been saying it for months
that the Maga Republicans the America
first fascist is I call them here are
the let's go Brandon Nazis that's what
we call them here we don't call them
semi-fascists they're full-on fascists
but their plan is to try to win the
house and you think I've been saying it
that I that they want to make Trump the
speaker because a lot of people don't
understand you want to be a member of
Congress to be the speaker
um so tell us about what your what your
idea there is and out while I bring up
your Tweet here
well yeah actually I've tweeted it for a
while and it's something that in the
past Tony we never would have put the
stuff out there because people would
have said well that's crazy that's
tinfoil hat conspiracy stuff uh but I
think we're well past a point where we
can say that anything regarding Trump is
tinfoil hat conspiracy stuff because the
worst thing that we can imagine he does
and then he goes even beyond that so we
know that Matt Gates and others have
talked about this uh Republicans win the
house that's why this these midterm
elections are so important Republicans
win the house and they can make Donald
Trump speaker you do not as you said you
do not have to be an elected member of
Congress to be speaker of the house and
when I tweet this and I'm sure you've
gotten this response from people when
you've noted that this is a plan for
some they're shocked they say that's not
true because you have to be an elected
member of Congress no you don't uh there
are some Democrats I know who you know
want to change this there's been
legislation introduced but it at this
point in time you do not it's never
happened before it's always been an
elected member of Congress but again
with regard to every Everything
regarding Donald Trump we are an in
uncharted waters so yes uh there are
some Republican members of Congress who
plan to win the house and right now if
the election were held today it does
appear Republicans would win although
that Gap is closing uh but they would
make Trump the speaker they can elect
him speaker if they would have the votes
McCarthy isn't going to do anything he
will step aside he's not going to
challenge him we know this whatever
Trump wants Trump gets other people who
said well Trump wouldn't do that job
he's too lazy well that didn't stop him
from you know being president for four
years he is lazy he would just Outsource
the job the actual job to somebody else
first and foremost for Donald Trump
right now is he wants in these
investigations to stop he wants to avoid
indictment and the way you do that is to
fire Merit Garland well how do you do
that if you are speaker of the house you
are two heartbeats from the presidency
you are second in line to being
president you are right behind the vice
president
so we already know that the mega
Republicans are violent
insurrectionist election deniers who are
willing to kill they were trying to
assassinate Nancy Pelosi on January 6
and hang Mike Pence we know that um
members of the Secret Service detail
assigned to then Vice president-elect
Kamala Harris on January 6 quote missed
a pipe bomb in their Advance sweep of
the DNC prior to her visit I don't know
how that happens
so we already know what the mega
insurrectionist violent uh cult are
willing to do they would take care of
those first two heartbeats and Donald
Trump as Speaker would then be installed
as president he can immediately fire
Garland and all of the investigations go
away and if you don't think he's capable
of this then you haven't been paying
attention not just for the past seven
years but his entire adult life so yes I
do think this is the plan for some I
think that what President Biden did in
terms of drawing a clear line between
these radical violent insurrectionists
and perhaps some semi-sane Republicans
who are left you know he's trying to
separate them out and show them the exit
ramp to try and save our democracy so
this is scary stuff but you know we do
have to talk about it openly don't we
well me and Gabe have been talking about
it for a while
um I mean you just can't avoid this
stuff and like just like what you said
because it's dangerous and the reason
why is because there are a few who have
this plan I don't know if this is Donald
Trump's mind it does seem kind of
delusional and far-fetched that that
that that you can make the mechanisms
all work but that is trumpism in and of
itself right I mean the idea that they
could they could just crown him King
with the vice president saying well I
just gonna make anything up that I want
and Trump's the president was
far-fetched and delusional but it didn't
stop them from trying it I guess that's
maybe your point here in this tweet
because I want to I want to read it here
it says so that um so that GOP wins the
house in November and makes Trump's
speaker his Violet manga take care of
the two heartbeats in front of him and
he becomes POTUS fires Garland in the
investigation indictments disappear just
like when sessions Whitaker and Barr
were a g so
Gabe we've talked about this before
mm-hmm
and we've watched as these folks as
Sherry put some insurrectionists like
Lauren bobert Matt gax Marjorie Taylor
Greene even Steve Bannon who maybe we'll
get to here in a minute
um
did this but don't you don't you guys
think that this is really
I mean it is wildly delusional don't you
guys think well yeah I mean I mean
absolutely you you've got a group of
people that are so detached from reality
that you know even from the beginning
right there were there were rumors of
there was going to be a Face-Off
situation like the movie between Biden
and Trump there was going to be
um the reinstallment uh of of trump
which a lot of people online I saw last
night were like oh this is Trump coming
back to DC to become president again
it's like well size were really excited
last night weren't yeah no no totally I
was like I doubt I highly doubt that he
would be in golf attire and that would
be the thing that he'd be walking
through you know into the Oval Office
but you know whatever but it very much
is a group that is detached I mean this
is the same group that was like we're
gonna release the Kraken
event it's gonna happen right these are
all these people that are believing in
some crazy far-fetched fantasy right
whether it's some Q Anon conspiracy or
someone else believes they interpreted
the constitution of how it was
originally written by the founding
fathers years ago and there's some
subtext that no one else is reading it's
crazy but they're really what it is is
it's this delusional confirmation bias
right they all want it's just like Trump
we learned during the January 6 hearings
and even before that
he would take he would not take no for
an answer he wanted it to be a yes he
wanted his his power to be in stated for
however long he wanted to be president
and he wanted only the people he wanted
yes men and yes women and when he saw
those people that said no or this is
outlandish or crazy he found ways to
remove them or replace them or find
people that would say yes but isn't that
the point near Sherry that like I think
that's what you're saying is it's not
everyone who's completely off the rails
here it's this Q Anon this dangerous
conspiracy theory
um thread in that Maga Republican party
who will believe just about anything
they're told especially if it's from the
Cheeto dust monster himself don't you
think that's kind of the danger here
well that is the danger here and that's
why President Biden was appealing to the
saner voices in that are left maybe in
the Republican party uh so that they
don't want to be a a part of the crazy
minority when people say oh but you know
half Biden was insulting half of America
no he wasn't it was probably 10 to 30
percent of these people that believe
this however and I think this is
important to remember if Trump wants to
be speaker if the Republicans win they
will let him they will cave to that they
will do it because they are afraid of
this angry base all of these republicans
in Congress caved and now some of them
actually are Republicans but remember in
2016 when trumpers went running for
president establishment Washington uh
and elected officials and party leaders
were not backing Trump they all fell in
line once he became the nominee or or
when he won and since then you know
they've sort of filled up a lot of these
House Seats with mega Republicans and
the others have been forced to Pivot
just to keep their jobs so if Trump
wants the job a speaker
um if Republicans win the house and
Trump wants the job it's his it's his
and I think we just have to accept that
nobody in Congress no Republican in
Congress is going to say no to him
period particularly if they've got you
know the wind at their backs with a win
because of gerrymandering and and other
things so you have to look at the
craziest thing I mean think of you know
seven years ago when we thought could
anybody have dreamed that Trump would be
president that any of this could have
happened no we actually thought as I
think Nancy Pelosi and Democrats in
Congress did or hoped and Susan Collins
thought that after the Mueller report
he'd learned his lesson be and they
didn't impeach because they were afraid
if they had impeached maybe none of the
rest of this had happened even though
the Senate wouldn't convict so never
ever ever think that Trump or those
people who ha see a pinprick of light
and they can push through through
violence or anything else cheating uh
don't think they're not going to do it
because every single step of the way
they have every time
right well and and George will even
pointed out this morning he was on
mourning Joe he's been trending on
Twitter this morning because of his
answer uh his first answer to the
question he kind of well I said it that
he kind of blamed Joe Biden for the
Trump trump and his supporters to be a
bunch of trees in his [ __ ] that
that's how I put it but Mika
um you know she didn't give up on this
thing here she actually re-asked him the
question and he gave sort of an answer
on what you're saying let's listen to
what George Will said about
mygo Republicans being scared of Maga
itself because most Americans are not
tuned into this stuff most Americans are
raising children going on with their
lives I'll ask you about these
Republicans and what has happened to
them and you John I mean you had some
things to say about but about Joe Biden
and the question is about these
Republican leaders in power right now I
I want to point out
um Miga you know women are going to save
us here because she even has to point
out leaders in power like hello hello
think McFly think like she she's really
pointing out here that you were asked
not about Joe Biden that's not what you
were asking but you were asked about the
Republican leaders that are sycophants
here so let's listen to his answer who
can't seem to quit him who still
to a huckster
and I've got to say George more
disappointing to me friends
family members most of the people who
voted for me in 1994 when I was very
clear about being a small government
conservative very clear about Where I
Stood on issues there is nothing that
Donald Trump is saying that remotely
reflects where you were or where I was I
I I'm trying to figure out why were were
they so open to this huckster who was
not conservative the answer to the why
and amica's question is they're afraid
of their voters
that's the problem it's a very
interesting phenomenon a political party
led by people who are terrified of their
voters if you're terrified of your
voters you can't really like your voters
very much but they are afraid they only
will think they have to fear is being
primaried from the right and they do not
want to enrage the intense base
and that makes them ineligible to talk
to the broad middle it's an old Axiom in
American life I actually think he's a
little off here Sherry I think when he
says that he's scared of them because of
being primer and I think that's a bunch
of [ __ ] I think actually some of
these Republicans are terrified because
of physical violence they're being
they're being threatened with physical
violence that's one thing that we're not
seeing some Democrats release some of
these voicemails that they receive at
their Congressional offices at their
homes the text messages the DMS that
they receive you know you know that it's
going it's going to Republicans as well
so you know that's part of the the thing
is the The Fear Factor of violence not
just primaries yeah yeah and I mean I
get those too I just got one before
coming on your show I got an email I
mean it happens all the time
um I think it's violence I think it's
compromat uh as being primary it's it's
the whole nine yards they're they're
afraid of it uh they're afraid of trump
they're afraid of of Putin they're
afraid of uh the hardcore Mega radical
violent uh insurrectionist election
denying Maga uh and so the only thing
they can do is hope that this message of
you know I think there should be an ad
that's that that if not Democrats but in
a line group put out this is this is
remember the old the old ad uh the old
commercial this isn't your father's old
mobile Oldsmobile they should this isn't
your father's Republican party and they
should show this and they should have
Liz Cheney with her father standing
there and saying this isn't my father's
Republican party and they should show
clips of the violence and the quotes and
and all of the things that this is not
and then end with you know Ron Reagan
with a picture of sitting next to a
picture of his father saying and this
isn't my father's Republican party
because Democrats don't need all of them
they just need some of them in the
midterms and and and
you know Ronald Reagan um was able to
get these Reagan democrats to vote for
him and stick with the GOP for a
generation so Democrats can't castigate
these people that Joe Biden was trying
to gently guide towards the exit ramp of
sanity and saving democracy you can't
castigate them for being Republicans you
can't ask for Penance you can't say but
40 years ago whatever you voted for
Reagan and and do all that that's not
how you win elections closer elections
are won or lost in the margins and this
is the margin you have to say join with
us we disagree on a lot we could but we
agree on saving America and and they
have to be more afraid of Maga taking
over than of Mega
um if that makes any sense because you
have enough republicans in Congress who
secretly probably wish and hope that
Mega would go away that Trump would go
away but as long as it's there pulling
the strings you know and they say JUMP
these guys are going to say how high
well I think you're right
um that you know they you know they wish
that he would go away because then they
have an easier time of the tail wagging
the dog I think that's what George Will
is trying to say here is the tail is
wagging the dog which I think it has
been doing that for a long time I
actually think that's Donald Trump's Mo
he walks into a room and he's like okay
where's the tail who's got the tail and
who's wagging it and then he he becomes
that dog right like any not just a
stadium but any room he walks into and
speaking of him walking
I have to we got it we have to because
he was actually walking last night in
golf shoes I have to go over this
because like we said earlier both sides
are really excited apparently about this
little video that was put out I found it
on Twitter I posted on our account
there's a longer version on YouTube I
linked to the longer version on YouTube
to the person who originally uh shot the
video I think
um in in the Tweet but here is just a
little taste of what happened last night
adoles says the Cheeto dust mobster came
off as itty bitty tiny private plane
one's launch
you see they're getting uh some luggage
out here
and um
it doesn't appear that they're in a
hurry so I I doubted that this was a
medical issue from the very beginning
but you're gonna watch here very soon as
they're climbing in to get the luggage
into the other vehicle
you're gonna watch Donald Trump exit
here here he is it looks like he has a
Maga hat in his hand and there they are
there they are Sherry there's the white
shoes there's the white shoes before he
gets into the into the van now a lot of
people were speculating last night all
over the place some were saying oh he's
being arrested he's in handcuffs which
he wasn't
um some were saying maybe he's coming to
testify before a grand jury maybe he's
being charged and he's gonna
self-surrender for an arrest maybe maybe
he's just needs more Big Macs in the
McDonald's in the DC area has a lot
better Big Mac than the one over in New
Jersey
um you actually said that Jared Kushner
has this America first fascist rally
that they're doing today maybe that's
where he was going to show up some are
saying maybe that's what it is what
what's your take and why does this
matter that he showed up unannounced no
Fanfare in his golf attire it seems like
he hopped on the plane very fast and it
was unplanned and what's your day going
well initially it seemed like it might
be a medical issue not enough emergency
to go to an emergency room but certainly
to get him
um to Walter Reed relatively quickly and
that's why he was still you know had his
golf shoes on I don't think he was
coming uh to this area I'm in the DC
area I don't think he's here to golf the
weather report was bad uh and it would
have been announced and maybe there'd be
people with him
so it could be if he does go to the
Jared Kushner speech Maggie Haberman
claims that he wasn't and of course we
know that she is the Trump Whisperer for
money for profit yeah yeah and
um so but if he does go there or if
there are people at that event and if
there is a message that he needs to
deliver personally or documents that
need to be exchange exchanged uh in
person
um he would do it even if it's to see
his son-in-law in a different Forum you
know or he could be moving documents
around from his DC Area Properties
Maryland Virginia but it does seem to be
related to something like that this was
it seemed like a relatively impromptu
trip or he he could be secretly
surrendering I mean all of the things
that people are speculating
um could be true but I think what's
important is to note that first of all
nothing is coming out of trump world uh
to explain or deny anything his family
doesn't seem to know he hasn't been on
Truth social so there's something
different going on and what's
interesting is notice all of it seems
like it's really bad for him it's all
bad news and the fact that we don't even
blink an eye that he could be selling
documents hiding documents destroying
documents meeting with people to deliver
secret information
having a serious medical issue I mean
when it comes to Trump again as we were
discussing earlier nothing is too
outrageous or tin foil it's not a
tinfoil hat conspiracy think like a
criminal get in his big
ugly white golf shoes and think if
you're in Trump's position and you're in
this much trouble what are all the
possible things that you will try to do
and then assume he will try to do them
right well I think between the time he
was on the blaming got in the car that
was probably the only time in the last
few hours that he wasn't climbing
um here is um here's the book cover for
Maggie hamrin's new book for profit on
the backs of the American people I'm not
going to play the thing but in in the
book she claims that he is you know
again he's predictably unpredictable
like you're saying and of course he
would have done the delusional thing
that think he could just I'm just not
gonna pack my [ __ ] I'm just not gonna
pack my [ __ ] and not go anywhere and
I'll live in the White House and be the
president of the United States
um what do you make of the Diet Coke guy
as his advisor for why he should stay
and then I want to move on to another
footage of uh airport airport footage
that happened a few months ago when you
because you brought up the documents but
yeah but what what do you make of this
book a Maggie uh first of all you Maggie
writing these books for profit this is
her second one in very short order and
holding on to this information that it
that could have uh saved us from January
6th could have saved lives and she's
holding on to this information
um when reporters do that I have a
couple questions first of all the source
is for the books what are they getting
in return for being sources for her
for-profit book and why are her
employers allowing her to do this
um I think that she could be I think she
should be sued for it for reveal I think
any reporter should be and I think their
employers are the ones that should do it
as long as you are a reporter
um and any information you get uh
belongs to your employer employer if
you're an employee
um this information belongs to your
employer uh if you are freelancing out
there doing this stuff for a book you
should no longer be uh protected under
the that what how the Press is protected
you know they're allowed to to not
reveal their sources
um this is sleazy uh it happens too
often and we've seen it where when lives
are at stake so uh if Maggie Haberman
had information in advance
um uh like this it could have saved us
from um some of the the problems on on
January 6th had she reported it as a New
York Times Reporter uh but this
for-profit stuff with reporters holding
on to information is not going to change
in terms of his advisors I mean look at
the people he's hired that he relied on
in the past so Diet Coke guy doesn't
matter I mean uh he hired Kaylee mcineny
as his press secretary the job that
Marlon Fitzwater had you know and uh and
you know really incredible talented
people like you know Mike McCurry and
Kaylee mcanania is exactly zero
political experience prior to Jeff at
CNN Trump's little buddy creating her
out of whole cloth and building her up
for Trump so he could make her this
person behind the podium
um doing and saying things that no
self-respecting actual political
strategist press secretary I've been a
press secretary would ever do so Trump
has a long history of elevating
unqualified
and unethical people to positions they
could never get within a mile of I'm
going to put kellyanne Conway in that in
that category kellyanne had been
upholstered and a TV pundit but had
never ever worked for an elected
official and you know and it showed so
yeah she didn't like Trump either she
didn't read it either well she was for
sale and so was her husband you know
George put flop back and forth you know
several times uh but uh so Trump didn't
mind if you let loose here on the
journey yeah it's fine
so he hires these people who will do
anything and they also don't understand
the job they really think that their job
is to take orders from him to tell him
what he wants to hear and to they don't
even know where the guard rails are
um and so those guard rails are already
down and he has a long long history of
doing this and it's very very dangerous
believe it or not
um it really is a profession those of us
who have done it for decades you know to
be a political strategist
um
do you think do you think Maggie
Haberman uh because me and Gabe have
Gabe we talked about this several times
do you think that Maggie Haberman is in
some sorts in some way a political
strategist where she frames the you know
she's so close to Trump where she frames
some of these stories and it appears
sometimes she's she's trying to be a
journalist but it appears at other times
that it's only in the favor of trump and
maybe herself but yeah isn't that in
that the story of trumpism and Trump
World it's access journalism and he
rewards it just like it was alarming to
me when he basically was handed the
reins to CNN in 2015 and 2016 and he was
calling the shots and when he was doing
that
um at Fox News I mean I I had been in
the business for a long time I'd been on
TV thousands of times of the course of
20 years I worked on Capitol Hill I was
a party spokesperson I you know ran
campaigns did the whole nine yards uh
but and you always expect certain media
they will once the primaries are over
and you have your nominees you knew that
fox was going to lean right you knew
that MSNBC would lean left you knew that
CNN would try to you know be in the
middle I had never seen this in a
primary when there were you know 15 16
candidates to see
um these uh TV networks just capitulate
and do his bidding and it was chilling
and I was living in New York at the time
and I would be in the Fox Studios you
know a couple times a week and I'm
seeing this happen and it was just so I
kind of had a little bit of an advanced
notice of you know my personal
experience with Trump to know what the
rest of the country now knows which is
why I don't think anything is so
far-fetched in such a conspiracy you
know tin foil hat uh possibility with
Trump because I've known it for seven
years
um and it's alarming but again back to
your point about the people that he
believes I mean he installed his
daughter and son-in-law in positions I
mean they couldn't even get security
clearances because they were they were
so uh so bad so we we've we've seen this
we've seen you know the people that he's
installed called and his his acting um
you know acting AG like Matt Whitaker
and other people who probably would have
some real problems again making it
through Senate confirmation so he's like
ah I'll just make them acting and that's
how he gets around it again he's knocked
down all the guard rails and
unfortunately too many people have
allowed them and Maggie Haberman is one
of them
well something something you bring up
yeah I was going to say something you
bring up totally agree with and I think
Tony does as well like the the my
biggest uh
uh frustration or pet peeve or whatever
you want to call it I mean is you've got
you know Stephanie Grisham Bill Barr uh
Maggie Haberman Bob Woodward these are
all people who had
very pivotal crucial information
especially Bob Woodward when we're
talking the covid uh pandemic these are
people who had access when it was when
it happened to know that either there
was intentional line there was
misinformation or there was a
distraction method happening and then it
wasn't until you know 18 months later
when they said hey I've got this book
coming out and it really is this profit
over people where it's like the you know
what is the What is the
the betterment or well-being of the U.S
American citizens and to those people
they said I'd rather take the sign-in
bonus and the deal with the publisher to
hold on to that juicy gossip or whatever
it is that put our lives or our country
at stake and say I'd rather just take
that instead of actually do my job as a
reporter or a journalist or whatever it
might be to actually report on these
things as they happen so we're aware of
it and we can prevent
a much more catastrophic problem from
occurring and I think that you know
again to your other point about like who
he actually hires we see right now there
is no legitimate high-powered attorney
that is willing to take on this case you
know not willing to touch it with like a
hundred foot pole right now he's got
these TV lawyers that are throwing up
crazy legal theories and accusations I
think they even just responded to the
motion yesterday or today as to the 100
classified documents and it really is
this thing of trump says I need to get
away with this and they're like well I
guess we'll just throw whatever at the
wall and see what sticks
because you don't want to say no we have
to say yes because you know I and I also
don't know
why these people agree to it whether
it's Fame because we know they're not
going to get paid at the end of the day
so you know really is that desire of
building yourself or you know I mean we
got James trustee who's who was hired
from seeing him on Fox news on TV right
these are we literally have these
lawyers who have no experience or some
of them do but not all of them and this
team is like ragtag team of Misfits that
in the end is like there isn't going to
be this Underdog Story it really is a
team of [ __ ] they're gonna
you know mess it up well you don't want
anything to get away with it and they
get away with it yeah with it um I but
focusing on them I think we have to
focus on us we have to focus on our
media that props these people up who
says it's okay uh you know like people
at CNN if you're a CNN contributor you
can't speak out against Maggie Haberman
because guess what she's also a CNN
contributor
um that's why I didn't play the piece
for CNN I put it out there on on Twitter
so that everyone can see it you should
go watch the the full version of it but
they do they they just act like ah no
big deal you know it's great that she's
putting this information out today kind
of thing yeah yeah and so you know we
see this over and over again but we have
to we should focus on us why are we
allowing this why are we buying the
books uh why are we not you know
speaking out uh a lot like I mean you
see a lot of people speaking out against
Maggie Haberman but again you see I also
see a lot of blue check marks if they're
even at other networks they're very very
careful to speak out against one one of
their own so to speak and in some cases
I know at CNN you know they are
specifically told you cannot criticize
uh somebody else who's on the network
well so great so that means when CNN
hired uh Corey Lewandowski or Kaylee
mcinany with zero experience or they
have you know Michael Caputo on who is
responsible for Untold I don't know how
many uh coveted deaths when he was at
HHS you know trying to infect as many of
us as possible and Jimmy around and
manipulate the CBC kova data uh once the
executives the TV Executives decide to
put these people on and treat them as
respected professional analysts they
have to treat them as colleagues uh it's
it's all over uh Scotty Nell Hughes was
hired at CNN remember her and she went
on to work for Russia today and she was
the one that was suing Fox News because
she was having the affair and she's
married she's having the affair with
Charles Payne who was also married and
she was suing him because it was well
known that if you have an affair with
these guys you get a contract and she
didn't get a contract so she was
literally suing because she had sex with
him but she didn't get a Fox News
contract so why I mean that's how messed
up things are
um you know and and CNN hired her as a
political analyst or political
contributor uh so you know we see this
over and over and over again uh so and
part of it is us that we defend this uh
that these people are propped up who
shouldn't be
um you know kellyanne was a known
repeated liar and she was being put on
TV all the time and then has this you
know top book on the New York Times
bestseller list so you know we can blame
well we should look at the people who
are being hired and what they're getting
away with what their bosses or letting
them get away with but we allow it they
they they don't they can't do this
without you know the public going yeah
okay
well you know you everyone's you're
bringing up lawyers and [ __ ] and
all these people around Trump who just
capitulate and I want to show you a
bunch of people who either capitulate or
didn't know what the hell was in these
boxes
um there is another piece of airport
footage that kind of got uh swept under
the rug from the golf shoes the golf
shoes to kind of uh overshadowed this
piece where there seemed to be cartons
As Trump put them
um eight of them I think is the count
here and I actually have a video that
counts them here on the screen of these
boxes that were taken and I believe this
is back in May I think it's May 8th they
reported it on May 9th and am I correct
in that Gabe yeah because May 6th was
the Nara uh letter that was like Hey the
National Archives where they were like
hey everyone our [ __ ] back and they're
like we don't have it and then May 9th I
believe it was when this happened and so
you're like three days later they're
moving on May 8th and I think it was
reported on me oh okay yeah so within
two or three days there was right yeah
this this happened
so let's play this and then we'll talk
about the the lead up to this and then
the aftermath and then the lead up to
today there's a motion
um because we're running out of time
here but I want to show this
there's one box
oh there's two three four oh man these
cartons are heavy they're heavy
some suitcase oh it's five and six boxes
there
we're gonna get um seven and eight
they're seven and eight I believe
again a lot of stuff going into the
plane there's seven and eight
so these being loaded in
um and you know I can show Donald Trump
going into the plane but I mean
obviously he does now this in the lead
up to this because like Gabe said and
then the National Archives was like hey
we need our [ __ ] back this is all
missing and he's like no it's my stuff
and they're like no no it isn't it's our
stuff and and this idea that somehow
it's a storage issue and they just
wanted to keep it secure no they knew he
needed to keep it secure because it was
top secret classified stuff and Nara was
freaked out they were freaked out that
this guy took this stuff and they're
like you need to keep it secure more
secure than Mar-A-Lago we need that back
and it got to a point where and again
this is the capitulation that people do
with this [ __ ] buffoon because they
capitulate capitulate capitulate until
they get to a moment where like okay we
just got to get the Department of
Justice involved in this to go down
there and get this [ __ ] this is this
could be criminal you know Nara is not a
is not in a criminal investigative body
they are Librarians literally they are
Librarians trying to make sure they
archive our history our country's
history is what this is this is going to
be a part of our history one of these
days and this idiot was taking him down
and storing them in the pool house down
at Mar-A-Lago now
um this morning they filed a motion uh
another I'm rubber your glue type uh
defense here where it's like no they're
his and prove prove that they're
classified what have you read this
decision Sherry what do you make of this
uh this motion this morning that they're
fine well I've I've read sort of the
overview of some of this stuff what
they're looking at first and foremost I
think is
um this this part of the law that says
if you are caught with this material and
you're mishandling this stuff
um then basically you can't run for
office again you can't hold office so
that's the first thing which I think uh
hopefully Merrick Garland is doing
something about you know you do triage
first retrieve the documents secondly
make sure this guy can't run for office
again so if he broke those laws
um that would apply so I think his
lawyers are trying to make it seem as
though it wasn't government material it
was his so that takes care of that layer
of problems for him but he's also
obstructing justice and in an affidavit
filed I guess by the FBI within the last
couple weeks they note that they have
video evidence that he was moving and
hiding this material to obstruct justice
so that's what this video is I initially
thought it was maybe a security video
that they got at Mar-A-Lago but I think
it's probably the video that you just
showed because then I remember hearing
right after it happened
um right after the raid shortly
thereafter that FBI agents were alarmed
at some video evidence that they had so
we've been hearing this so what this
does is it puts Trump in Jeopardy
legally on a number of different issues
so my guess is that they're trying to
make it seem like well he that law
doesn't apply to him or he can't run
because he got caught with this stuff
taking it removing it mishandling it
because if they can make the case that
it was his instead of belonging to the
government that eliminates that problem
I I think I think you're right that it's
that um this is more evidence like these
motions that they're filing and because
I think he's actually just doing what
Trump does is delay here like he's not
really he doesn't really have any kind
of defense or throwing everything up
against the wall to see what sticks yeah
I mean there's no spaghetti monster yeah
there's also like you say the delay
tactic which he's done with past vendors
contractors whoever might be because his
goal is list I've got this money
somewhere that I can use to uh to
litigate as long as I want but the
government's like all right bet let's
see how long you can last because the
government you know you endless resource
of and it's a criminal investigation
right exactly and the government's like
look we've got a big budget we can keep
going with this
yeah but here's here's the problem and
this is this is where it shows that
Trump is still pulling the strings on
everything because still controlling the
timeline in the agenda he obstructed
Justice for months and months and months
and months and months
bumping us up to this point where now
we're in that magical zone of the
midterm elections and this supposed you
know the doj policy not law but policy
where they won't indict or even really
um uh robustly investigate of 60 days or
90 days whatever before an election now
Trump isn't on the ballot and since it
was Trump jerking everybody's chain all
these months uh and not returning the
documents purposely delaying by
obstructing justice now he's protected
by that doj policy it's insane uh he's
the one that got us to this point where
we are in that zone before uh midterm
election but he is not on the ballot so
doj uh Merrick Garland you know honoring
that somehow is is is just insane it's
beyond comprehension uh that Trump is
being allowed to get away with this I
mean we're looking at this video
watching this stuff it's like he's
breaking the law he is a danger he's
should not be running loose so he's
probably blackmailing the government
saying hey I'm going to release these
secrets in these secrets I got more and
it's all going to come out if you arrest
me you know who who knows there's
there's we're either letting him go
because he's been indicted on nothing uh
and Trump is above the law or there's a
lot going on behind the scenes that even
the really smart people can't figure out
it's one or the other at this point
um but it's alarming that he is roaming
free
well I I think you're I think you're
right and I appreciate you uh joining us
Sherry and hopefully
um there are more signs and more
evidence that the doj is moving on him
like a like a [ __ ] and and grabbing him
by the top secret documents because I
actually believe that that is the case
that is to be made very quickly here
because
um it's kind of black and white you know
not to give a pun for documents but it
it is kind of written in black and white
there exactly what this is and and you
know they keep saying the presidential
um records act they keep bringing that
up as if that's is going to say yeah I
mean James trustee's throwing out this
article too which is like that is not at
all what Article 2 gives you would you
would you interest unlimited power
Sherry would you trust a lawyer that you
saw on TV who's whose character name is
Trusty trustee Jim trusty trust me I'm
Jim trustee would you would you believe
this and and before we go he's the only
anything you want before we go uh well
okay I have a podcast that I started up
restart it up again after a 15-month a
hate is due to cancer
um but my podcast is on patreon and his
politics with Sherry Jacobus I hope
you'll tune in my uh follow me on
Twitter at Sherry Jacobus
c-h-e-r-i-j-a-c-o-b-u-s and my website
is Sherry jacobus.com
give us one last take on trustee there
what do you think you know he can't he
can't well no uh just because he took
the job he can't pick his last name but
it's my understanding that
in a very long time that actually has
you know some chops uh so
um you know some legal chops um ethical
chops who knows what sounds like the
attorneys are hiring attorneys because
Christina had to seek which I would be
curious to know who's who is her
attorney at this point like who's
willing to take the case that she might
have obstructed or been involved with uh
the mishandling his documents we'll get
to the bottom of it I'm sure we get it
Sherry thanks for joining us don't be
you come back please come back soon
anytime you want to talk
um we are open to any kind of talk here
on the Tony Michaels podcast we welcome
all pro-democracy speech here so thank
you for joining us and everyone stick
around we're gonna go to the [ __ ] list
Roundup we're gonna serve the Tweety
tweets and journey Trends we get a lot
of footage to get to right after this
break don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages thank
you Sherry